zwar zähle ich nicht erreicht als ich
mir blieben die mit abstand stärkste
elf stunden vorher
ich hoffe es wörtlich
gemeint ratings bühler und schmiede
hotel befindet wert in der spitze
könnten die große wanderung von
demonstranten verloren die kultur die
gold ja und
wer sind wir sind wir besser als die
anderen
was niemand ahnt es schon jetzt an die
beiden immer so schnell gehen
braucht es grenzen damit wir wissen wer
wir sind
[Musik]
als vater um meine
28 kandidaten gross stand übrigens um
die marode und im vergleich zu den
anderen kondome hat die ausnahme
wir sehen den sonderfall mich stellen
zum sonderfall und um sie mit uns
die welt aus der sicht von rechts außen
euro
super
[Applaus]
[Musik]
setz dir klar
ich habe
stockers angenommen
ja ok
im svp land wird der wahlkampf nie auf
es ist februar als ich meine expedition
zum nährboden der partei starte
reiseführer der zürcher kantonsrat
claudio schmid und kantonsrat kandidat
roman schmid schmieden schmid vom
zürcher unterland sie leben in der
anflugschneise des flughafens kloten
oben die weite welt unten rechts
konservative scholle
schönefeld dapd
si
oder stimmung geändert und jetzt da
[Musik]
das trage das stabilisiert schmiede und
schmiede auf lokaler wahlkampftour es
ist sonntag und es ist kalt
das ist früher werden bauern die svp
heute sind es menschen in der
agglomeration
[Musik]
hemdsärmeliges plakatieren das svp
leitmotiv es wird mich das jahr hindurch
begleiten
die münchner quartieren in bünde
dies zeige ja das gehört mir und das ist
verständlich dass man das muss ein
großes event
personen kann druck setzen wir nie
gemacht
und
ich habe irgendwo
[Musik]
gemacht er kommt mit einer mail über bio
ist zwei shows gestanden
das mache ich jetzt
verstanden
und
ich erinnere hier
[Applaus]
bei unserem ersten treffen stellte sich
claudia schmied vor mit den worten ich
bin ein sozialisten fresser
[Applaus]
sie sind ja eigentlich ganzen
entspannende manch vierfache
familienvater
die frau ist
von der svp zürich oder sie wären nicht
ideal fürs
empfehlen
das haben wir schon mal gesprochen ich
habe mit der verschiedene lösungen
aushandeln
schmid ist nicht der einzige der zuerst
für ein porträt zu sagt nach rücksprache
mit der parteileitung aber nur als
funktionär auftreten will der zürcher
sekretär yves gadient schick mir die
sprachregelung dass persönliche sollte
keine rolle spielen parteichef alfred
heer sorgt ein dokfilm bringe der svp
gar nichts etwas bringen würden 1000
libysche flüchtlinge an der grenze die
stimmung ist aufgeheizt die dauerkritik
der svp sie gilt auch im unterland beim
schweizer fernsehen würden nur linke
journalist arbeiten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
generalversammlung der svp bülach im
besten lokal des ortes
mit servicepersonal
das beisammensein stärke die gesinnung
die partei aus großfamilie
[Musik]
hier mag man es gemütlich umso brutaler
kling claudia schmied ideologie
als sozialistische
versuchte arbeits vernichtet zerstörer
erhältich sein was es gibt ja nur zwei
potente svp unterricht und drückt sich
die frau
alleine deshalb event ich kann schweiz
kann artgenossen eidgenosse gleich
gebürtiger schweizer schweizer gleich
eingebürgerte ausländer bei der svp
führt heimat liebe zur
zweiklassengesellschaft
unter den waren alt genossen ist sie
eine der wenigen aktiv politisch ihren
frauen bei der svp
die junge frau und ich bin auch schon
mit der svp aus bronze und das ist da wo
mini mini werk zu können
mit einer christlichen und fdp sich für
miese fliesst in der wm besser ich bin
eine gute stelle
sie lebt dort wo sie als kind
aufgewachsen ist auf dem bauernhof ihres
vaters die eltern gleich nebenan andrea
spieler ist mutter von vier kindern der
kuchen selbst gemacht ein leben wie aus
dem bilderbuch
wieso alles angeschaut
[Applaus]
praktischer wo es
okay
die country kultur erinnerungen an die
jungen jahre von andrea und jörg spicker
ein leben in den usa aber sei nie zur
diskussion gestanden
viel zu groß sei das land und zu pompös
schon ihre heimat sei nicht mehr
dieselbe richtig städtisch seit
mittlerweile leider mit vielen
ausländern ein ganzes quartier würden
sie bevölkern 23 prozent sagt die
statistik schweizer durchschnitt
der erfolg aber ist immer noch derselbe
hier hat sie schon als kind angekauft
die kassiererin wenn sie welt war nur
svp
und die findet so richtig power und das
wo sie auch sie denn nicht nur redet
davon ja alles landet trotzdem dass ich
uns landes
länderkollegen kalt und meine tochter
nicht alle kühe oder etwa auf
ich bin keine 1000 gewalt billig und
will ausländer in der schweiz das
problem dass
[Gelächter]
sie lernen portugiese der sich
integriert und jugoslawen mache ich die
erfahrung und die kann eine tolle
eindruck früher aber vielfach die sind
einfach anders foto kultur ganz
glücklich finde ich es ganz schwierig
andreas peters wohnort vor 40 jahren
wurde der
kirchenspitze
geändert ja wann zeit
soll sie uns gut an
wir
[Musik]
sind
beim besuch der nachbarin zeigt sich
andrea sprecher hat ein konkretes
problem mit ex jugoslawen ihr
zehnjähriger sohn can i und danach das
buch remo würden in der schule gemobbt
zu werden
sie hat einfach konkret seite zum knie
geschient schweizer und die polin und
treviso wird und wo ich versuche mit
zehn objekte machen also schön holstein
sowie während sich dann ein
chemieunternehmen
noch svp liess auch die einzigen
eidgenossen ihrer klasse ein multikulti
schulhaus
diese mädchen stammen aus anderen
klassen andrea spieler wie nicht dass
wir die kritisierten filmen
und was könnte hintergrund sie sind
erheblich besser wider schule aus die
restlichen dass rossi hier sich
rückblick macht wo hinter pro schüler
dreifach der bcm gefördert dann werden
also noch schwierigere aufgaben bekommen
und das sind schon voll und ihren
ständigen
im rahmen einer projektwoche besuchten
die schüler das open sein
also in der schweizer schon
[Musik]
etwas mehr
die kleinen probleme sind ihre großen
die weltereignisse weit weg fukushima
schlimm für die leute vor ort aber ohne
atomstrom geht es eben nicht
und die blutigen demokratiebewegungen in
nordafrika ich benötige
keine mühe mit den ergonomie sprechen
ich weiß nicht egal möglich
dass sie in nordafrika zum beispiel
erzählen die demokratie aufbauen
das gefühl gemüse das sie selber lehrer
aber wenn sie in der wirtschaft
sogar dass wir ihnen die dünne haut kann
das möglich schnell und ich glaube nicht
dass sie das kann man glücklich also
wieder sicher wieder kultur von der nyt
[Applaus]
alle vier spieler kinder gehen ins
multikulti schulhaus ihre eltern hatten
einen wechsel beantragt abgelehnt
[Musik]
fatale politik interessiere ihn nicht
sagt ehemann jörg in der sache aber
denke er radikaler aus seiner frau finde
sagte stoffen
löse das nicht so viel mitbekommen und
lehrer da ist gerade schwächere
mitbürger dass fortis gearbeitete
kriegsgerät und wieder mal typisch
wien energie gasnetz und weise wir sind
einfach da und
wenn wir nicht mehr da ist
andrea spieler ist eine interessante
frau sympathisch ehrlich und offen
erstaunlich wie schnell die
wertkonservative ins radikale gibt
ich bitte meine
und das wiederholt das wiederholte
zweimal wenigsten einig dass man das
muster von zwar mitunter gesamte familie
die lebensdauer jähriges kind ich glaube
ich immer bewusst dass man das nicht
macht das ist nicht einfach jetzt
fähigsten vorherigen kreuzfahrt am kiosk
mit sich selber wissen dass ich es um
recht und das macht mut und wann das
ist einfach so nicht extrem aber
irgendwo muss man muss ja auch ins land
ja aber ich glaube einfach nicht dass es
mit laschen siegesserie zu starten
sie ist es noch nicht so bewusst aber
ich mich seite zwölfjährige ich nehme
das auch videos sie nicht weiß dass es
falsch ist und es wäre besser sondern
von tagesschau
wie sich das paar durch abgrenzung
sicherheit verschaffen
das natürlich sie belehren die
hausgemachten aber wie sagt sicherlich
drücken und dadurch aus der schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
allein
[Musik]
sl
die filipina kommen ist die ehefrau des
lokalen svp präsidenten nach dem
philippinischen gottesdienst einmal im
monat pflicht der gemütliche teil im
seil hinter der kapelle dagegen hat er
absolut nichts einzuwenden sagt peter
frey hier trifft der kollegen die ihre
frauen so wie er im ausland kennen
gelernt haben
die cdu müsse jetzt kann schweizerin hat
sondern den philippinen
ja
kunden
natürlich gewinnt
so sieht sie die flammen ist
bei bedarf
die fremden erscheinen in der regel nur
so lange fremd dass man sie kennt
und
die unpünktlichkeit müsse man sich schon
gewöhnen aber es gibt ja auch vorteile
seit 20 jahren nun ist ehefrau carmen in
der schweiz an svp partei und lassen ist
sie mit dabei
die gut
sind sie selbst auch mitglied
aus dem bezirk sie dann ihre partei
[Musik]
sie habe 20
mit für ob der mann in seinem programm
ein
wenig anfangen
hier amtet peter frey polier im
hauptberuf source portal chef der svp
nach feierabend geht die arbeit oft erst
richtig los unentgeltlich natürlich
[Applaus]
auch
sagen er verwies auf die arbeiten dann
musste ich auch gar nicht
beim motorrad trainings ist die mehr
erfolg beschieden als beim geld und
unterschriften sammeln
nicht wirklich angenehm sei auch von der
parteizentrale bewertet zu werden
sondern konnte rief derweil hat das
natürlich ja ja wir sind im mittel waren
oder sind das sehen wir ja mal als fotos
rasen
rangliste ja was ist zu viel des guten
wenn wir damit mal geprüft worden sind
wartet sollte man auch die vermehren ist
nun verworfen
das ist
einfach immer
gestört wie man sein
[Musik]
dass der polier sich für die partei
engagiert ist reiner zufall
der frühere us-präsident hatte ihn
überredet plakate aufzuhängen
einfluss hatten auch seine chefs auf dem
bau alles svp-mitglieder
sie befremdlich aber ich war mit der
schweiz als journalist
muss ich noch nicht verraten
dass sie direkt an in trient erhöht
werden
fakt ist auf dem bau arbeiten rund 60
prozent ausländer
[Musik]
an die leute vom balkan habe man sich
schon gewöhnen müssen
[Musik]
verziehen
hat
[Musik]
heute würden andere probleme machen
großmann werden auf mich schauen sie
genau wie spritzig vor dem sozialismus
so frieren
aufstand
seines chefs und er hätten damals für
die personenfreizügigkeit gestimmt mehr
ausländer gleich mehr arbeit unterdessen
aber kämen einfach zu viele die
schweizer kultur gehe verloren
gehen dann auch erkannt ich werde wie
ein loser pro
verfügt
weiß weiß ich mitmachen werden auch
spricht sogar
die passanten mit einer meistens ist
immer so bei
ihm nicht schmeckt wenn ich nichts finde
noch gewisse zuerst wenn du warst ja das
ist schon schwierig titanic wie stehen
sie denn hütte personen
erhöht sich der stimme vor dem rund
627 dann tust anderer teil heute schweiz
nicht vom gefühl her
könnte mir aber jemand schafft mit dem
rapper eine
ausländerquote dieser idee hatte vor 40
jahren schon rechtspopulist james
schwarzenbach
überfremdet wohnungsnot betrogene spare
und alt das land nach bedroht die einst
lexis tanze das sind folge von einer
egoistische wirtschaftliche expansion
die kremers und drei mit bekannt
sieben menschen haben die schweizer über
die begrenzung der ausländer abgestimmt
und sie immer verworfen bisher
[Musik]
vis á vis von peter freys haus das drei
sterne hotel löwen
italienerinnen spanierinnen und auch
freis philippinische frau carmen
arbeitet hier die gefühlte zuwanderung
ist realität
kollegin christina stammt aus kenia
diesen job macht keine schweizerin
effizient durch der hat eine idee
sprechen euch gut der hat eine grammatik
gut alles ist das hier keine schöne
arbeit doch katja
w für mich ist social
dass mazedonien
sie sind ausländer sie arbeiten seit
jahren auf schweizer baustellen und sie
argumentieren gleich wie die svp
also langsam mit dem ski und langsam
langsam zieht uns langsam sehr langsam
übertrieben
wenn eine partei sagt ausländer
lieferstopp dann ist okay oder denkt ihr
nein ist schaut es gegen uns oder wie
denkt
die leute die haben es satt und sie
haben genug von der grenzenlosen
einwanderung zuwanderung in die schweiz
[Musik]
nationale partei stars auf heimischem
parkett
delegiertenversammlung der zürcher svp
zum wahlauftakt
warschau
[Musik]
ein hauch von ghana in der vorstadt
unsere richter brauchen offizielle
ständeratskandidat woche bezüge zieht
aus mit andere
eine bestimmte wege und eine tätig ist
größter brocken offizielle stellen
bereits
derartige plakatierer claudia schmied
sagt mir man nenne ihn heiland person
und multimillionär blocher unterdessen
71 jahre alt die svp macht den spagat
zwischen basis und elite in der
kriegskasse sollen 15 millionen liegen
das budget ist das bestgehütete
geheimnis der partei die transparenz
einfordert die jüngsten finanzstarken
akquisitionen der gescheiterte swiss
first banker thomas matter und
unternehmer hans ulrich niemann
er freue sich die wege nach ihre
grundtext der betriebe - pilz der
prozentzahl nach morgens ins rad an die
freisinnigen die mehrerer 15 prozent
zahlen wollen sie den über die teilung
und ich
[Gelächter]
stand
[Musik]
seinen wahlkampf lässt er sich rund
200000 franken kosten lehmann sagt er
wohne am untersten punkt im unterland
für unsere aufnahmen habe er den audi
gewählt im porsche und ferrari zeit zu
wenig platz
seine heimat ist dort wo schon sein
großvater gelebt hat hier besitzen rund
5000 quadratmeter land mit einigen
häusern
vom großvater her 90 euro bezahlen
und das ist nicht der hauptgrund
das ich denke die hosen machten die
opferzahlen übernehmen würde darum bin
ich eingezogen
ist auch wenig fehlt sie
nein
der unternehmer spricht von
opportunitäten und business cases jedes
gute geschäft eine persönliche
befriedigung sein jüngster coup eine
marode spinnerei die für 40 millionen
zum kongress hotel umgebaut hat
wochen sitzung mit seinem
bereichsleitern
gottfried
häuserer briefing
wochen lang die svp so sagt lehman habe
den freisinn als wirtschaftspartei
abgelöst gerade wirtschaftsfragen
das ist mitglieder von der svp
kritisiert dass mit 60 mal 60
mal wieder die galaxie politischen
ränkespielen gehört hoffentlich die
rettung schaffen und gleichzeitig so
dass ich bin cvp ist verständlich nicht
dass das nicht klappt so leicht wie der
svp wurde für bekannte schmier
politisieren aber ganz klipp und klar
und wie
sie den erfolg der svp r8 und alle
einfach nur
der erfolg der svp ist wohl kein ihrer
wirtschaftspolitik geschuldet
danach hat der
ex jugoslawe und
problematische sich für 50% druckstellen
sind ist unser land 67 musik das ist
eine fremdsprache wechseln
[Gelächter]
lehmanns torriani tellerwäscher karriere
200 bis 300 millionen schwer werde
geschätzt zu 90 prozent war es glück
sagt der handy könig lehmanns firma
atronic war in den 1990 er jahren
generalimporteur für nokia-handys
faktisch eine lizenz zum gelddrucken
der wirtschaftsliberale hat vom
abgeschotteten markt profitiert nach dem
zucker sage
aber ich bin nicht unzufrieden sind ich
bin volles risiko egal vor niemand die
das dorf iga mann entzog riesch einen
monat risiko avantgarde und noch gilt
dass man sich das wohnung spüren
gespürt hatte es auch im fall der handy
reparatur firma mts in österreich
lehmann war verwaltungsrat er hörte die
geschäftsleitung würde die bilanzen
manipulieren
die firma ging später konkurs die
angestellten wurden entlassen die
aktionäre verloren dutzende von
millionen
dank seinem wissen aber ist niemand
vorher zurückgetreten sein aktienpaket
hat er vergoldet
halbzeit zurück schaffte
unabhängigste firma gut so und tschüss
aber wenn sie sich öffentlich gemacht
hätten sicher dass dank also offiziell
mit die kritik wird optional zum
dearborn
naja ich glaube das thema xxi runde
nimmt also heraus gar nicht auch zu
nennen hatte vor fünfte macht hey du
liebst sms kommunizieren
und gehört so der vorwurf ich meine
gemacht wurde ich hoffe ich verwende
konsequenzen wir sind ja nicht so
dass
sich jemand stammt aus einfachsten
verhältnissen seine biografie erinnert
an jene von christoph blocher dort der
pfarrerssohn und gelernter bauer hier
der ehemalige körper stift sein vater
ist letztes jahr gestorben
auch sein vater sei es fatal gewesen die
mutter wie nicht politisieren sie sei
einfach froh dass es ihren vier söhnen
gut geht speziell dem hans uli
wir
sind sondern so
einfach
mit der größe
kollegen kann auch ihr auto mit starker
in der proa hans ganze zeit und wir
haben zwei rückkehrer christian was
machen
diese auto de stellt und die suntory
ziehen und man hat das sexuell opfer
sicher sehr viel frauenpower passen wie
viele autos genau besitzt wenn er nicht
sagen
25 oder 30 die leitkultur sei ausgeprägt
in der schweiz
nur emrich ist derweil reduziert auf
zwei bis dreihundert millionen das ist
das was mich stört der staat immer ein
mensch dahinter und dann sie reduziert
aufs
bankbürgschaft sehr gut dank
ein anderer kleingewerbe
die schweiz wie sie der familie spieler
gefällt
musiktradition in unsicheren zeiten
wir sind nachhaltig zu halten mit der
woche in hoffenheim weiterhin und sofort
in allersberg und dann irgendwann
nationalen streiktag
inzwischen entstanden und
andreas bee kritisiert dass die partei
mit blochers nomination aus
ständeratskandidat druck ausüben
eigentlich in wähler aber sich nicht
getraut zu nahe stehen hört das war es
ich bin sicher dass es hergibt sagt
schätze mal als ehemalige bundesrat
abgewählt wird
nur
für sport interessieren die bislang am
herzen dann
wenn da einfach meines kapitel abschluss
sind ich generell im lager und ist
schnell wieder aufbauen
sie solle sich besser vor der kamera
zurückhaltend sagen der
gemeindepräsident und andere svp aber
die 39 jährige steht zu ihrer meinung
ihr größter politischer erfolg eine
betreuungsstätte für kleinkinder
verhindert zu haben der kinder habe
solle sich selber um sie kümmern wie ich
mache wenn alle einbeziehen die mutter
wohl nichts muss coach auf ihr sich das
flugzeug eigentlich logisch dass
alleinerziehende monate gratulieren das
kind noch wie ich die situation gibt es
ja immer wieder aber vielleicht müssen
wir halt als hobby gefördert wurde sie
stärker in erinnerung rufen und mit
haltegriff
weil es ja nicht gerade sagen immer
vermeiden zum anderen hüpfen
und da
die busse
die svp familie keimzelle des staates
und nicht selten reich an mitgliedern
multimillionär lehmann und seine frau
erika haben fünf kinder einen
schwiegersohn und eine schwiegertochter
lehmann 27 jährige tochter ist bei der
evangelikalen freikirche als sängerin
angestellt
[Musik]
die familie besucht dort gottesdienste
unternehmer lehmann spendet ein zehntel
seiner einnahmen und dividenden dem fcf
dogmatisch sei er nicht aber die werte
des ef seien auch die seinen hier ein
paar seiner überzeugungen in kurzform in
wilder ehe bei hunt zurück bleibt
also sex vor der ehe
ich finde das thema oxytocin rossmann
übernehmen selection verantwort die
meisten sich das auto und der frau lernt
gerade einmal müssten entscheiden sie
mal war geriet der
naturfotograf transsexuelle menschen das
defizit oder saft
cavaliere kann vom vater ob sie sind
aber eine richtungs glaube wenig
gerettet da fangen mehr das heißt ich
habe dann wohnen in hemer
der übergang von wertkonservativen sv
kehlen zu evangelikalen ist fließend
unternehmen lehmann ist jeden monat
unterwegs nach wien zu einer
tochterfirma seiner holding
sein wirtschaftsprogramm die
mehrwertsteuer so stark erhöhen dass die
bundessteuer abgeschafft werden kann die
reichen würde es freuen die
ultrakonservative tea party in den usa
argumentiert nicht anders
der geschäftsführer von lehmanns
tochterfirma auch ein schweizer und svp
ohne markus kobler würde er nicht in der
fremde geschäften speziell nicht in
österreich überreguliert über
subventionierte ein graus
das kann geschehen würde
das überhaupt nicht haben
das hat jetzt kann die bdsv petrescu
[Musik]
größen aus
seinen angestellten in wien bezahlt
nehmen ein drittel weniger lohn als in
der schweiz können uns nicht nach hinten
lehnen und denken unser business case
ist gesichert wir haben unser tägliches
brot ist
nicht so der nationalratskandidat macht
geschäfte in und mit europa was sie
nicht daran hindert gegen die
personenfreizügigkeit zu sein dafür
politiker namens politik nur bis zur
nasenspitze jährige selbst in einer
hochkonjunktur situation ja hat das
alles bürger vertrag aber die schönheit
der konstruktion man die mozart und das
ist im raum das ist aber es ist absehbar
dann sind problemen thermax gegangen ist
können wir mit dem christentum
hat wieder eingang wie die der inländer
forderung der alten dame ist die csu
mache eine bewiesen dass sie da kann ich
werd ich finde das richtig stark mit
ansage nehmen sie eine frau ist und weil
ganze
schon mit unternehmerischen entscheid
ich nein nur sie profitiere jetzt
einzelpersonen fleißige 37 ostern
platzieren der schotte kann man auch
noch einmal profitieren
die multi kulti schule von bülach die
meisten eltern sehen sie aus gewinn für
ihre kinder auftakt zum sommerfest
die
[Musik]
taktisch sind 7000 euro
vertreibt schweiz nicht mit hoch
qualifizierten spieler carola voelkel
3261 produkte überall
[Applaus]
[Musik]
den haben hintergrund war ein gedanke
dass anfang der barfußpark corp
[Musik]
richtig so
die themen hohe das waffengesetz hat
sich seit jahren sind mit der infostand
der politik
es ist nicht neu sagt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es geht jetzt so schön die leute sagen
oh sie sind werden kartoffeln oder
aussagen oder stroh
gestopft so sie aber das ist klare
vorteile und nachteile haben alle teams
schwer gefallen trotzdem die meinung der
svp gemeinderätin zu multikulti schule
ist gemacht aber sie toleriert explizit
dass ihre zwölfjährige tochter die welt
mit anderen augen sieht wo mir davon
erzählt
diesmal mehr gedanken über deren leben
[Musik]
sich ja jetzt
aber ich bin der
[Musik]
richtige mann das land und um das
relative gruppe sprachen die unteren und
und das ist das wo jede wirkliche
identität ideal bahnen mit dem kollegen
die mit wirklich geschafft hat
und dann geht es in die sommerferien
wer schafft der ausflug ins emmental für
die spieler kinder
die insel kate kommt an der us-ostküste
sommerfrische für wohlhabende amerikaner
und die siebenköpfige christen familie
nehmen
[Musik]
auf tour durch die eu peter und kommen
frei
wir sehen nicht so einfach zu beweisen
wie viel ich die mittepartei
[Applaus]
nationalratskandidat lehmann im
wahlkampf
ist die kamera nicht dabei erledigen
dass seine angestellten alleine während
der arbeitszeit
und überleben ausstellern gottes zu
den bachelor wegkommt den petrus
wechseln
das ist
auch sie folgen dem ruf der partei
peter und kommen frei unterwegs zur
ersten tüv landsgemeinde der svp
hunderttausende schweizer fahren
motorrad in den augen der partei brach
liegendes wählerpotenzial die parole
freiheit statt schikanen waren wir schon
alles war normal was der eu macht dann
seid ihr wenigstens was die deutschen es
erlaubt im deutschen osten wie der
schweiz machen könnte doch wenigstens
100 fahrer auf der autobahn ist es zum
teil der golf reise in die schweiz macht
von der eu profitiere unbedingt der eu
beitreten auf keinen fall
ich möchte mich hier de
reisen its nicht zwingend dass man das
gefühl habe ich heute zu kreieren
offenere haltung gegenüber der eu oder
überhaupt nicht
eindringlicher auftrag wird zum großen
moment der orts präsident ist auserkoren
den volkstribun auf den pass zu
chauffieren
damit das gut
stolz
natürlich
momente der euphorie inmitten
domestizierter rockel vier wochen später
dann wird die erfolgswelle der svp
gestoppt und zwar abrupt aus der traum
von 30 prozent wähleranteil
die svp fällt auf 26 6 prozent das
potenzial scheint ausgeschöpft parolen
provokationen personen haben sich
verbraucht
wenn ich jedoch die tempojagd wurde das
will ich
das so nicht sein es ist kaum zu fassen
die strategen seltsam gedämpft wie vom
donner gerührt
ihre 20
22 ein wenig
so wie
jede sturz hätte sturz des aufgestellt
hatte konnten
maschinen die am isas krieg die schüler
großer brocken von größe zurück verheißt
sie haben
[Musik]
die svp vom zürcher unterland tollen
abgegrenzt wünschen sie sich eine
schweiz unter heimatschutz
dabei könnten sie verbunden sein mit dem
rest der welt eine welt die nicht stehen
bleibt
[Musik]